hello reject nation it's Greg Alba good
and I'm John Humphrey today we're gonna
do another list video one of our war
tears on patreon is whatever video you
request we must definitely do usually
those are reactions which are cool to do
but this time Rosa Parra a lovely lovely
woman mother to many children
devoted wife sexy lady with a great
personality she's like the Lady Stark of
our patreon that's what we like to call
her and I don't know if you guys ever
saw we did a vlog where we visited her
and like surprised her over the visit
and gave her one of her the shirt that
she ordered yeah so she's such a great
woman and she wanted us to do our
favorite Pixar movies so today we're
gonna do our top five favorite Pixar
movies which is relevant to
end-of-the-year family times holidays
Pixar's all about the family so let's
hop into this list we'll do a countdown
five five four four thirty you know how
it goes let's do it all right so my
number five pick is Toy Story 2 Toy
Story 2 is a damn good movie and
choosing from three Toy Story movies
that are all great this is the one that
has always impacted me the most I loved
the adventure I loved the story of woody
finding out his lineage you know the the
show that he comes from how much about
being collectable he is how he has like
a bigger line more than just being
Andy's toy and it also has that side
adventure with Buzz and the other toys
trying to find woody so you get this
adventure element then you also get this
personal life element of woody and you
know you also get the inclusion of
Jessie who's great it's a great addition
you even get Zerg and if you get the
sci-fi stuff you get that cool badass
opening with Buzz Lightyear yeah you get
a whole buzzing Zerg little little yeah
at the end that's when they include
Barbie and in this one too I really
think this one is the funniest one it's
just as heartfelt as the others some
might cry a little bit more at Toy Story
3 for me this is the one that really
impacted me and I also feel the
intensity of the film is just as
powerful as the comedy
movie and that's why it's my favorite
toy story of them all that's a good call
actually it almost made my list but
because you included at it I decided to
leave it all behind but I do think of
all the toy stories it has the best
blend of humor and fun and stakes and
drama yeah my number 5 I went with a
bug's life for whatever reason I watched
that movie a ton growing up and they
introduced the bloopers yeah that movie
is one of my earliest Pixar memories I
mean I know I saw Toy Story I think it's
the second Pixar movie yeah and I
watched it a ton and it just you know it
touched my heart I think Dave Foley is a
really nice lead is flick this is just
the world and the different characters
and stuff it's not the most original
film they've done but it does play all
the emotional strings the right way and
I do think it really holds up as as sort
of a harbinger of what's to come from
the studio and in terms of vintage Pixar
I always enjoy what I put on so that's a
well it's a story of the little guy
being able to go up against the bigger
guy yeah it's a cool story my number
four pick would have to be the sci-fi
adventure wall-e wall-e is a film I've
only seen once I have this Anil that's
movie-going experience sometimes with
certain films which is if I loved the
experience so much in the theaters the
first time I see it I usually wait
forever until I forget about it so I
could try to recapture that feeling just
one more time and Wally has that effect
on me and it probably higher up on my
list if it was a little more familiar in
my mind but I remember the feeling
really well for a film that takes place
in the future
it's a quieter film I love this story of
Wally and is it Eva
or Eve yeah Eve and the story of these
two machines one's a lot more highly
advanced than the other but it's also
this beautiful love tale and it also has
some great social commentary on where
society is headed so it ends up being
this profoundly deep sci-fi experience
which is really honoring the sci-fi
element by being a commentary on our
modern-day world and where our future is
heading while at the same time just
being a beautiful quiet film
for number four I went with Coco partly
the reason I put in at number four is
because it's more recent it's gonna take
some time to figure out where it stands
for me in the grand scheme of things I'm
a huge fan of music I just love the
world I love all the mythos they brought
in from the traditions of dia de los
gatos it's rich with culture but it's
also a wonderful adventure and it's got
great music and some pretty a stirring
intrigue that I wasn't expecting
especially later on in the plot when
things start to get hairy like I was
sorry yeah I was surprised where this
movie went it really left an impact of
me so I think it'll definitely stay in
my top 5 it left an impression I really
enjoyed it all right number 3 for me
another Pixar classic I notice all my
pics are ones about world exploration my
number three pick is Finding Nemo
Finding Nemo to me is one of the more
powerful emotional ones and that's why I
put it up there because it's a story
about essentially a fish overcoming his
trauma from losing his wife you know and
then all he has to hold on to is his son
and I'm a sucker for stories about
parents especially anything to do with a
dad that one really got to me a lot
because it's a story that has such a
strong core it's literally a story about
this one character going across the
world just to find his son who I'm
missing and that's what makes Pixar so
brilliant taking this tale a fish that
we think of just in the millions of them
billions of them and they're not the
smartest creatures in the human eye but
then exploring it in a way if they had a
strong emotional depth he also get the
really fame beloved favorite character
dory
included in this movie and I love all
the exploration of the different types
of sea creatures there are and then you
get the birds and there too it was it's
a really really funny movie that truly
tugs at the heartstrings and then I
think it's one of Pixar's most
beautifully animated films well added to
for number three from me I went with
ratatouille which was another one that
surprised me and you know I like to cook
yes so this movie sort of appealed
driver simpler films but just as
imaginative yeah yeah yeah and it's got
you know a nice couple different stories
going at the same time you know you
the story of linguini but you've also
got Remy the rat and they make a nice
oddball pairing and it's just about you
know it's about passion and the things
that you do to pursue that even when you
know the cynics are out and whatnot and
the French bistro vibe and everything
was a nice new aesthetic zo2 and I just
I really liked all the emotional strings
of this story too it really stuck with
me yeah right absolutely
my number two pick was actually John
already mentioning my number two pick
would have to be Coco Coco yes well
that's a strong factor is like what was
housing how am I gonna feel about it a
year from now or a couple years from now
when I saw that movie
there is no Pixar movie that has made me
cry or move me to tears as much as this
film I think this is that Pixar movie
that has pretty much everything
excluding like cool action I can't think
of another Pixar movie that has such
great musical numbers such a deep
respect for a specific type of culture
as great exploration in human world
culture and afterlife culture I think it
does some daring things with its darker
elements there's some great messages
about family tradition following your
heart following your passions to me this
is the movie that best represents all of
the morals and themes and messages that
a lot of Pixar movies try to convey
while also just having a really
captivating gripping intense plot that
keeps unfolding and has surprised twists
in there that I just really didn't see
coming it was a very powerhouse film to
me and easily one of my favorites of
2017 funny enough my number two his
movie you have mentioned already and
that would be wall-e which really
surprised me it's probably the most
different Pixar movie I've seen because
I mean up has some heart-tugging sad
moments but wall-e to me is the most
melancholy of all the Pixar it has the
most air inside of it for so much of it
you're kind of just alone with this
silent character and it grabbed me so
much and also just things that are heart
heavy things that are more world-weary
tend to resonate with me a whole lot and
yeah the view into the future of just
this race of fat sloppy humans you know
camping out on a spaceship just all
getting food and TV pumped in
yeah yeah yeah it's the Mac of future
lay yeah just that movie really stuck
with me even still and it's not like
I've watched it a million times but it
it always comes back to me with that
same rush of emotion I yeah at the first
time it was really a next-level moment
for me in Pixar for sure and now before
we unveil our number one we should
probably some honorable mentions because
there's a lot of great Pixar movie Cars
two cars to finding door I need doors
University cars three the good dinosaur
no I mean like there were ones where I
was looking at him like man there's
people are gonna give me crap for not
putting it on here but you know there's
so much is super powerful any of the toy
store any of the annoy story movies yeah
Monsters Inc inside out is one that's
not on my list but I'll just give me my
number one cuz I have a feelin might be
John's number one I don't know my number
one is The Incredibles The Incredibles
to me I like what can I say I mean some
I just write it off as another great
superhero film but to me this is the
definition of why animation exists
because there's yet to be a live-action
superhero movie that matches the caliber
and imagination that you can do with
animation the way they do it with The
Incredibles
it's very heartfelt it capitalizes and
brings to life so many of the things
that would just look silly or cheesy in
a CGI live-action film and makes it
really powerful here it's got great
commentary on comic book superhero types
of stories the the design and animation
is just so intense and the action scenes
are so cool and actions one of my
favorite genres so this to me has it all
I don't really like tear up when I watch
the movie which just seems to be the way
I judge a lot of my Pixar movies how
often did I cry I don't really tear up
but I'm always wildly entertained I'm
still moved I love each one of the
characters in the film and I'm a sucker
for superhero films so yeah this would
have to be my number one favorite Pixar
movie is a good choice and that is a
movie that I need to revisit at some
point because that's one that everybody
adores that I liked a lot at the time
but I I need to go back and sort of
refresh the memory my number one
you're right yeah yeah cuz that was the
most I was kind of blown away by a Pixar
movie I love the conceit that the
emotions are all broken down into
different characters all part of a
spectrum existing within one person I
thought that was a really great visual
metaphor I thought the ways they set up
the mindscape was great and I love this
idea of like a high-stakes emotional
scenario playing out inside of
somebody's head while also her life is
happening I just thought like the
complexity of the story they drew was
great the journey of the world was a
really fun adventure but again it's one
of the Pixar movies that has a very
strong lively emotional core and I like
the message that it you can't just be
joyous all the time like to me you know
as a person who who has dealt with
certain emotional issues over time the
idea that you mean sadness and you need
fear and you need anger just as much as
joy there they're all important as parts
of a spectrum was a profound and a
sophisticated message to me to put in a
family movie act that and I thought the
way that they realized it was terrific
and since I've seen it you know it
hasn't left me yeah so I really loved
that movie yeah it's it's definitely my
number one Jon's always fearful sad and
angry you know yeah that's right and
that's why he loves it mm-hmm disgust
see this is why I'm the way because I'm
supposed to be fearful Saturday yeah
well I get the message people find it
the controls oh you know good it was a
good example to set so that maybe I can
chill them it's a reassuring message
yeah yeah yeah well and also just the
stakes become huge when you're watching
this this little girl get despondent
you're like oh my god what if emotions I
love that meme what feelings had
feelings well guys that's her list for
our top 5 favorite Pixar movie is what
are your favorite Pixar movies put them
in a ranking order and more importantly
do you agree with our list and if you
don't do you hate us do you think we're
not worthy of putting up free YouTube
videos now that you disagree with our
opinion you're a real Pixar fans put
your comments down below guys you can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification
oh so you get notified every time one of
our videos is up you can follow us on
the patreon
patreon.com slash the real rejects it's
like a second youtube channel with some
extra perks and also download and falls
in the stardust app merry new year
because we're past Christmas now